we've seen a lot of sort of casual
discussion of impeach Trump what might
he be able to get impeached for we now
actually have democratic Texas
congressman Joaquin Castro who is asking
Congress to investigate whether
President Trump intentionally exceeded
his constitutional authority with regard
to the majority Muslim country
immigration ban this could
hypothetically lead to impeachment
proceedings against Donald Trump but
don't get yourself too excited because
even if that's exceeded then Mike Pence
might be President of the United States
so the back story is that the lawfulness
of Trump's ban on immigrants for
majority Muslim nations was called into
question by a federal court they put a
restraining order on parts of the
implementation we've heard anecdotally
that there are some Customs and Border
Patrol agents that were continuing to
ignore the court order and basically
follow the letter of the Donald Trump
immigration ban so here's where the
logic is if Donald Trump in some way
directed Border Patrol customs and
border CBP DHS whoever to ignore what
the court said in suspending parts of
that ban he may actually be opening
himself up to impeachment proceedings
here is a tweet from Joaquin Castro
where he said quote if President Trump
ordered CBP to ignore a judicial order
he should be censured as a warning if he
does it again
Congress should remove him the legal
concept at play here is that if Donald
Trump is giving orders to DHS or CBP
that defy a court order he is quote
living in a military junta Trump's
explicit references to the Muslim ban
may also actually justify impeachment
proceedings with regard to the
separation of church and state this
actually isn't the only basis on which
impeachment of Donald Trump could be
explored the house could also
investigate the possible violation of
the stock Act because
Trump's possibly still lasting
involvement with his company so there's
a number of different aspects to this
bottom line though there's so many
emails we get calls when we take live
calls when will Trump be impeached sort
of two things here number one
Trump's impeachment is going to depend
significantly on a Republican House okay
so that is going to be an uphill battle
to begin with and number two why do we
want Mike Pence to be President of the
United States and I know that Trump
because of his ego and his thin-skinned
nature if Donald Trump were to be
impeached it would really be the height
of embarrassment for a guy like Donald
Trump but but if you have Mike Pence in
there you all of a sudden may see the
sort of coalescing of the ideological
religious conservative aspect of the
Republican Party around pens and you
might actually see more damage get done
under a Penn's presidency than we may
see under Trump yes so impeachable
offenses include everything from bribery
treason and other high crimes and
misdemeanors not specifically defined by
the way right and out of that list I
mean what sticks out to me probably
bribery I mean we don't know his tax
returns
what other conflicts of interest he may
have and get out of that list I think
that's the most likely one path any
House member could start impeachment
proceedings we know we have this
Republican majority in the house they're
the articles of impeachment must be
passed as Pat mentioned you have to have
an agreement that there was a high crime
or misdemeanor committed by the
President of the United States and then
the conservative Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court John Roberts would preside
over a hearing in the Republican
majority Senate which would have to vote
by a two to three in a right not not two
to three with a two-thirds majority in
favor of impeachment of the President so
maybe Joaquin Castro is trying to make
himself look good for 2020 does it even
really matter I just don't know that
we're actually better off with Trump and
peached and Mike Pence as president of
the United States from a purely
practical perspective well it's
interesting because I think these
establishment Republicans in Congress
would much rather have
and charges and Trump so if impeachment
proceedings were to take place it would
come from within his own party that's
interesting
Republicans themselves may prefer Pence
over Trump because maybe they see it as
more conducive to than actually
achieving all of their legislative goals
and they may be able to even reach
bipartisanship and reach out to
Democrats on the other side huh
I see resignation is more likely than
impeachment I see just like at but if we
see the ninth circuit uphold the
suspension of Trump's immigration ban if
we continue to see everything Trump does
just get destroyed maybe at a certain
point Trump will say you know what I'm
out even in his first two three weeks
we've talked a lot about the comparisons
between Trump and Richard Nixon yeah he
may resign under threat of impeachment
interesting yeah interesting that
actually seems much more seems much more
plausible than an actual full
impeachment proceeding right I mean it's
ever happened fully there you go yeah I
know that many in our audience are just
desperate to start the proceedings but
we have to know number one not only how
it works but number two what the impact
would be and I would not hold my breath
waiting for the successful conclusion of
impeachment proceedings against
President Trump Warby Parker is offering
a free five day home Tryon to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial com slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
mine cost and for every pair of glasses
sold Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at-home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing